Mélina bonsoir les Ukrainiens on la
prend qualifie ce c'est le Fleurus
d'hypocrisie
tout à fait Stéphanie à la première
réaction qui nous est parvenue vient de
Mirail au podologue le conseiller
spécial à la présidence de volodières
zenenski qui s'est fendu d'un tweet à
cette annonce je le cite premièrement
l'Ukraine n'attaque pas un territoire
étranger et ne tue pas de civil comme la
Fédération de Russie et le fait et
deuxièmement la Fédération de Russie
doit quitter les territoires occupés
seulement à ce moment-là nous pourrons
parler d'un cessez-le-feu temporaire et
c'est là qu'il a prononcé cette phrase
garder l'hypocrisie pour vous une
hypocrisie car effectivement pour les
Ukrainiens hors de question de pouvoir
accepter un cesser le feu temporaire
tant que les russes seront toujours sur
leur territoire vous l'avez dit en
propos introductif il s'agit d'une
demande du patriarche de l'Église
orthodoxe de Moscou Kiril qui a demandé
expressément à Vladimir Poutine comme
erdoine l'avait fait dans l'après-midi
de lancer ce cesser le feu temporaire
unilatérale sauf que voilà et bien ce
patriarche qui rit il est très critiqué
en Ukraine très proche de Vladimir
Poutine il soutient la guerre menée par
le le chef du Kremlin et donc ici l'une
des lors des symboles les plus
importants pour montrer à quel point les
Ukrainiens veulent justement s'éloigner
de et bien cette église orthodoxe russe
c'est que et bien cette année pour la
première fois l'Église orthodoxe
ukrainienne a proposé aux Ukrainiens de
choisir de fêter Noël soit le 7 janvier
comme ce que font les Russes ou soit le
25 décembre et l'immense majorité de la
population au travers d'un vote fictif
un vote pardon en ligne notamment à
voter pour ne présente majorité pour le
fêter le 25 décembre alors pour tous les
Ukrainiens avec qui nous avons pu
échanger il s'agit non seulement d'une
hypocrisie mais aussi d'une énième
provocation et disent que cela permet à
Vladimir Poutine de passer pour un bon
samaritain en quelque sorte de faire
croire que c'est lui qui est de bonne
volonté alors que c'est lui qui a envahi
le territoire ukrainien et donc pour
tous les habitants et bien pas de cesser
le feu tant que la Russie sera sur leur
territoire et tant qu'il n'a pas tant
que les soldats russes n'auront pas
quitté les territoires
occupés étant que même la Russie n'aura
pas quitté la Crimée annexée en 2014